mike what time of day is it yeah
seriously it's so well lit
was that sun me it's sun it's because
you're seeing me in
daylight for the first time oh cause
we're recording also
because we're so early yeah i didn't
know you existed during the day
yeah i mean i kind of don't it's fine
why does your room look different it's
like oh because it's not
night that's right i just assumed you
lived in some kind of
ninja turtles subterranean lair so it
doesn't even matter what time of day
yeah i did say this before we started
recording but my light's not working
which means i have this like i want
focus well my hair is being keyed out
because the reflection of the green and
i have this
this ray of light because of the time
[Music]
thank you it's really hard from this
very good that's like my favorite
music cue in the entire uh even with the
theme and everything
just that um it's like a warm blanket
just resting around
i love i know we've talked about it but
i just can't resist the mention of i
i love the little cameo of that in last
crusade
when they're in the what's that what is
that yeah
you sure sure pretty sure uh
you know why he's pretty sure because
john williams is saying
that's it that's the one you said it you
said it
uh austin i told you i was going to ask
you about this i'm going to ask you
about this
what you did a thing in person
in front of you i know you talked about
that i had a concert
i mean he tweeted about it so i hope we
could talk about it
it was very top secret yeah how did it
how did it go what was the
process i mean i assume this is your
first one that you've done everything
every time i send a tweet i think i'm
sending it to just you guys and so i'm
always like who are these other
responders old man doesn't know how to
use twitter thinks he's google searching
but actually it's on his twitter
timeline
it's funny tell you do it
one time i i i get larger right guys
i've tweeted hey can you follow me so i
can dm you
just publicly instead of adding the
possibilities
not my finest work on that one um and
then you pin it
uh but yeah austin what was what was the
process for that happening again and
like
i just kind of want to know like that's
yeah i guess you are
no no you are not wrong that it was the
first the last
yeah take it off baby the last i know
it's hot today
uh the last uh this this subject
makes me a little flush
the concert was um the last concert was
pax east
uh doing the super giant thing with
darren
in um whatever that was pax used last
year
like late february early march i guess i
think it was march
um and then and then after that the last
event period was
was uh when we were all at dice um
and so this was the first i've done one
recording session
in person i did fly to nashville in
january
for a day for some recording sessions
which are obviously
very controlled and very you know small
numbers of people
and so that was very different and
there's no audience obviously and
there's no like guests in the booth
like there might otherwise be this was
um
it was so there's a conductor friend of
mine who i've known for years and he's
been a big supporter he's conducted
journey in particular a bunch
and he texted me a few months ago and
just said hey you know this orchestra
that i work with in indiana
is is going to close out their season
with a show they're calling
fantasy night which will feature like
harry potter and star wars and stuff
and he said i'd love to do journey on
the show and if you would love to come
out for it
you can conduct if you like if you're
kind of you know
this was a few months ago so he said you
know we can kind of gauge it as it gets
closer but if
on paper that sounds appealing i can get
the wheels in motion
and he said you know look as you might
imagine budgets aren't exactly great
for orchestras right now we're not
swimming in cash given the complete lack
of sales
for the last uh year um
but i was like i i don't care uh i
i you know we'll we'll work out what
what
whatever you know actually the way we
did it funny enough is
the local university um is doing hybrid
in-person and online uh so they had me
come and do a master class and basically
the fee that
that that fee was what paid for me to to
you know have my expenses covered
because the orchestra just blatantly was
like
it's basically bring your own bring your
own music
at concerts and uh so but it was amazing
because
you know they were they were capped at
um 25
uh audience size and so what does that
mean people wise in this
in this space it was about 500 it was a
2000 seat haul
okay and um it's not nothing that's cool
yeah but so even
now they can't actually sell out even if
they wanted to well sure
yeah they sold out their 25
cap uh and they also did do a
simultaneous live stream
but yeah i i was amazed um
that i thought it was going to feel a
little depressing because you know
25 standing in front of an audience yeah
that's a quarter full
yeah but because because they
they did the seating so that people
could kind of like be in their little
bubbles
so that there was still distancing it
wasn't like the front
25 percent and then a sea of empty the
way it would normally be
when you have utterly failed to sell out
a show which believes i played those
shows before
me too i have my mom
thanks for coming yep yep i've i and it
is
it is so it is so it's awkward until you
just lean into it and you just tell the
audience
all right you know what you guys are
here so this is truly
and especially for you and they end up
having a good time but but
or one hopes but uh but this audience
that because they were
sprinkled throughout the hall to and to
do the social distancing it didn't feel
nearly as empty as the numbers
would suggest and um it was god it was
so cathartic
i i i i said i can't remember i actually
said this
when i was talking to the audience or
not but in my mind i certainly was
thinking
you know i don't even need any of you
here it's just so cathartic to stand up
in front of a proper orchestra again
and funny enough apropos subjects for
this crowd
because i was going all this way uh i
thought you know
i'm always thrilled to do journey we do
we do kind of the the main bits nascents
apotheosis i was born for this
and it was all well and good i was
thrilled to do it the orchestra played
it great we had a phenomenal singer for
the
for the song um but i was like i was i
went shopping as i sometimes do on the
rest of the program and said
what else is on this show that i can i
can conduct
uh that uh i can just kind of steal from
the other conductor
um and they were doing the theme to the
mandalorian so i said i'm doing that one
too
just to let you know that's awesome and
so you conducted that
so i was able to do the yeah the
mandalorian as as part of it
that that's that's a fun bit i imagine
so yeah
is that you like mike you just do this
and then the mandalorian theme happens
like a lot of finger pointing that's how
i direct
you accepted the very poor fee because
you just really wanted to to go
oh yeah there was no fee this was this
was expenses
yeah it was it was i want to stand up in
front of a crowd because here's the
here's the reality and i did tell this
to the audience
you know they they were very they were
really they seemed very
happy to be at an event so they were a
very generous audience very applaudy
and but i turned to them and i and i
said i want you all to give yourselves
a big round of applause because
um i've been basically sitting on pins
and needles for the last year worried
that this art was gonna die
because this is an art that tends to
live very hand to mouth
orchestras with very few exceptions uh
orchestras don't you know your you got
you got up to 70 80 people's salaries
you've got crews you have expensive
venues that require
insurance policies that are
non-elaborate that are very elaborate i
mean that are non-trivial
uh yeah the opposite is the thing that
you're trying to say
it is it is it is a it is a
logistic pain in the ass of an art form
and it is one that has always been
relative to the arena shows of the of
the pop stars of the world and the big
rock bands and you know hip hop legends
and all the various
folks that dominate like 10 000 person
arenas
like this is a far more niche thing
broadly speaking
yeah and um so
so it it requires an engaged audience
which
also is often inclusive in that is like
a donor base
and corporate sponsors and all that so
when you have an economic
uh pause or contraction like we saw
it's not an industry that's designed to
weather the storm it's just you know a
lot and a lot of orchestras just
fold they're like we can't go three
months without a show never mind a year
um and it's kind of habit-breaking as
well right like people if people
stop going they forget to go it's like
yeah
well not just that i think that's very
true but the thing that had me most
worried was
for the last year i've been reading
tweets and seeing posts on
instagram and whatnot of people saying
every time i look at like a photo of a
old party of mine from 10 years ago i
feel anxiety just seeing a group
that packed in together and i think that
there's still i'm still there for sure
like i think it's a it's a kind of
understandable collective trauma and so
i thought
people are going to be slow to want to
go back to these
concerts even if there's no barrier
anymore even if you know it's like
everyone's vaccinated
the virus is just omnisciently we just
know it's
dead like create an unnaturally
confident situation
there's still going to be a reticence i
think from people are like
you know i don't know i've gotten kind
of used to not
being surrounded by crowds and it makes
me feel uncomfortable
and uh and like i had a funny moment
with one of the musicians where we in
the rehearsal he did an amazing
solo and i i went down to give him a
handshake and he instinctively gave me
back an elbow so i gave him an elbow and
he replied with a hand and we both
looked at each other and go
we don't know how to interact with
humans uh we've forgotten so anyway i
just i told the audience look it means a
lot to me
that you guys came because it someone
has to
so and if they don't and you were the
ones who took up that mantle of
responsibility
and and had the kind of courage i think
to say you know what
you know probably i would imagine most
people in the audience had been
vaccinated
but but even if they hadn't there's a
certain amount of courage required to
just say
i i care enough about this art form to
know that like life will never be
fully risk-free and i want to do this i
want to support my local musicians and
my local
community and businesses and that sort
of thing and i said look to me it's not
a small deal that you showed up for this
concert it is an actual
act of will that has you've had a year
of encouragement to not do for
i'm not i'm not chastising that you've
had very good reason to not do this for
a year yeah
um but just know from me it is such
a tear-jerking sight to see
bodies in seats uh knowing that
that they could have done anything else
with that evening so
from that angle it was a spectacular
experience yeah that's awesome
ham pam just shot a wedding um
and it was probably the most unique
it's not even a wedding with an event
there's a multi-day thing
in joshua tree and
it was basically like burning man light
i mean there were there were art
installations you walked in there was a
full they had eight medics
um there was what are they planning
right that's a statement of intent i've
heard
i know a wedding obviously we're gonna
have medics
what happens if one person dies so they
they had like a
there's actually a medic there were two
medics who were getting two bags for
them
but you you arrived and there was a
testing center and and
um you immediately were rapid tested and
then upon
receiving your uh verification of
negative covet test
they would give you a choice of uh one
of
three bands that you would wear around
your wrist for the remainder of
the weekend uh color coded green yellow
or red
green meant bring it on give me hugs
give me kisses whatever you want
oh that's a really yellow idea yeah
yellow of course meant uh just ask me
but first
or or red of course was like i'm not
comfortable yet so everybody knew you
didn't have to go
what are we you don't have that awkward
weird elbow hand reminds me of
traffic-like policies when i was a
student
yeah what's that do you ever get
adjacent to the land parties
right it was it was a similar structure
of instruction but with slightly
different meanings but the
the reason like out with me the traffic
light party
obviously i'll sit at this point like
it's fine we're old now we don't do that
kind of thing anymore it's fine
the thing that it encourages me though
is that it's something i'm gonna be
googling while troy tells his story
about the the level of anxiety and i've
experienced the same thing where it's
like man are we ever going to go back to
normal because i'm i'm just
i'm a very affable extrovert oh my
i'm a very physical mike's gone very
physical
fine it's fine this camera seems to get
laggy off to like can't handle
ambient light that's the problem it
can't do it it's too much too much data
it was the traffic lights were
specifically i i i see
i see what you're up to now i got the i
got the uh urban dictionary
yeah okay anyway troy your kind of
social interaction like you
you are more satisfied with it if it's
physical
i am 100 like if you look at the the
love languages and stuff i'm physical
touch
and words of affirmation and so that's
been a very interesting thing for me to
navigate because
i if if i'm around you and i'm
comfortable with you and we have a
rapport
i'm gonna i like to touch your shoulder
i i'm just i'm i'm a touch person
um this has been an interesting way for
me to um
grow and go how what's a different way
that i can now communicate
i i think i've talked to you guys about
this before when we went to lockdown i
was like how am i going to expand my
mind and so i've been doing french
i've been learning french uh there's not
an advertisement for it but duolingo
it's a great app it is you're doing it
for
as of today 315 days nice
yeah and that's that's straight so i
haven't i haven't stopped for for almost
a year
and i it's because i want to be able to
communicate in a different way i want to
keep my brain sharp i want to be able to
do that and so
learning how to create learning how to
communicate not only just like
linguistically but also what's a
different way that i can communicate
because pam's is is not necessarily a
physical touch fan is going to be acts
of service so
in order to be with my person i got to
be able to speak her language
um but the thing that encourages me
about that is
is how quickly we can invent
a system that says we want to find
we don't want to go back but we
understand that things are different now
so how do we acclimate
and if we weren't able to adapt we
wouldn't be here as a species
it's the one thing that we inherently do
very well
sometimes two are to a fault sometimes
like aggressively and dangerously often
yeah
yeah right like we'll go i remember one
um scientist was talking about
um uh rising gas prices and and he was a
specifically someone who was a
climatologist and he was like i hope
that this isn't the reason why people
buy a hybrid because the second that gas
prices go down people will go back
it's not it can't be reactive it has to
be proactive and in order to do that
there must be an understanding that
oh this is the way that we need to
operate better but i'm encouraged by by
you being able to do that it's i think
that people
i'll share one less anecdote but i i
gave up meat
i i went fish only for like five years
and then i went to nutritionist
and i think we talked about this before
there's a whole book you can read about
eating your blood type or whatever
and it was like oh by the way your
specific blood type it's it's
harder for your body to process protein
from these other sources this is where
your body naturally wants to get it from
i was like okay because i couldn't i was
trying to gain weight and i couldn't and
so i was like i'm going to slowly
introduce me i have the same problem
me too i
full time um so i i i finally was like
okay i'm going to slowly introduce me
back into my diet
and i was going to have steak for the
first time in like five years and i
literally was like
i was i was hesitant to do it because i
was like i haven't had this and i had
this weird fear
and then and then i tasted it and it was
delicious and i love it
i think that what we'll all have to do
is just kind of go find someone that
you're comfortable with and go
someone outside of your pod someone
outside of your immediate circle and go
can you just give me a big hug can you
just can we can we be close together and
then slowly do you want to try that at
ralph's
you should it's like i don't know you
walk down to mcdonald's
i mean i uh because i had spent so much
of last year like completely alone
like you know in a studio apartment like
i would i went three weeks without
making eye contact with anyone at one
point
like it was it was a lot and then uh i
did a live show where everyone was
tested and you know we did a charity
covered relief thing
and i did ask a friend for a hug and it
was just
it was just weird like i was just so
aware of how strange the custom of
hugging is rather than being like wow
this is great i was like this is a weird
thing that we do
why why kissing is weird man let's put
our mouths
together it's a weird thing i mean troy
you're gonna be able to relate like
stage kissing ruins kissing the second
you've kissed someone where it's purely
because a script tells you to do it you
realize the
horribleness of that experience without
infamous feelings i can make it even
more awkward infamous second son
there is a there was a specific scene
depending upon which way you went
where um fetch and delson
in the script said violently make out
that was in the script violently make
out now at this time
um travis and laura were married
travis played reggie my older brother
laura played fetch
so um here's travis on set and he's
doing his damnedest to make it
even more awkward now laura bailey is
like of course yeah that's his role
yeah he there's a curtain and he would
just pick his head out he would just
point at us awkwardly
um but laura and i i
i love laura like a sister like she is
in in every way she is a sister loving
someone like a sister definitely adds to
the appeal of
making out this just has
everything going for it to be the red
that's a wrap this whole thing sounds
terrible
yeah i've got the band it was it was
hard like i've had to do a lot of
of really uncomfortable scenes and laura
i was like all right you ready to do
this let's do this
okay here we go and they're like well
we've got these face cams so we can't do
that like oh yeah yeah totally
so first what we want to do is you're
going to have to mime it
oh my god even so you're you're
awkwardly doing this
you're doing a demolition man style yeah
like
yeah they actually exchanged i was a
really good kisser
um and then you go we're gonna take the
helmets off and you guys are gonna
do it for real and it's still just what
my my mental my head cannon of of this
story is they're like
i see them all looking at the monitors
and they're like this chemistry we
should
we should up the ante on this scene this
shouldn't be a make out scene like and i
could just see them
rewriting the script to just raise raise
the heat
no no no i look at laura bailey as such
a mom
like i think i've only met her once but
she's the best auntie in the entire
world she's just
so much of just like this caring kind
warm
woman that i feel like if someone were
like now you have to make out with that
i'd be like i can't
but i can't do that to her she'd go read
me a book before i go to sleep or
something
like it would be either that or
for those that that i think i think
there's a lot of folks that she be
became they became consciously aware of
her even though they probably played a
million games that she was in without
knowing it was her
obviously the last of us is probably the
thing that made them go
so then there's the other side it's like
i'm scared of this girl
and here comes the fan art
oh no oh
[ __ ] here we did it to ourselves
[Laughter]
in fairness i wasn't even thinking that
way until you said it and now it's all i
can think about
uh but back to the topic at hand and not
to making out with laura bailey
um i oh you're right mike
i'm back it's gonna happen occasionally
i don't know what's going on but it's
fine
um i'm fully vaccinated and i've been
out
a couple of times and for me i feel like
i was uh
locked down to a pretty significant
extreme like i wasn't going to ralphs i
was like not going anywhere at
all um i didn't go to any restaurants in
the last year so
you're like asthmatic and stuff i mean
you're right i've had pneumonia multiple
times and been hospitalized
very good reason to be very it would
have been a
pneumonia is awful it's so awful
i don't think i've ever had it you have
to do you have to sleep on your you
can't sleep on your back
try sleeping at all you have to i have
to like if i've ever had it and again
every time you get it your lungs get
worse so
you're you're more likely to get more
sick the next time you get it scars your
lungs
they're like the more you get pneumonia
the worse this is for you in the long
run
and the fact that i've had it three
times they're like it's probably what's
going to kill you when you're old
cool great um is it also god doesn't
want you to exist is what
it feels that way it's australia this is
what you do is like everything's just
trying to actively kill you
none of that is is pneumonia it's it's
not a
disease that's a condition right like it
you develop pneumonia you don't get
you don't catch pneumonia is that is
that correct it can be contagious
certain kinds of it can be but
uh yes it is generally developed off of
like
another cult so you get sick with
something else and then you get
pneumonia
which is how it works in relation to
covid
um but yeah i mean sleeping on it is
like awful because imagine that you you
just constantly have like a swimming
pool in your lungs like
every breath you feel liquid move up and
down so you're you just
it's like it would be like having water
in your mouth and trying to go to sleep
but but it's in your chest you can hear
it
it like rumbles like it's just awful you
have to cough
every minute you know like terrible so
if i ever need to sleep on pneumonia
which makes it extra debilitating is i
have to like take a lot of
drugs to knock me out so i can actually
go to sleep
um and then the waking hours are just
this awful painful anyway
uh so i hadn't i hadn't been anywhere
just to negate that risk of not getting
pneumonia again and
and being hospitalized um and i wasn't
sure how i'd feel
uh going to i've been at two restaurants
um
one of them was like an open outdoor
thing the other one was not
it was completely fine like i was like
oh i'm immediately not at all concerned
i think i was like i was just amazed by
how quickly i reverted to
this is fine and nobody else
seemed to be concerned uh other than the
just strange experience of white stuff
having to wear masks and people's suit
of armor yeah which
like just made me i was like okay we're
tipping these people more for what
they're doing
in this process like they may not be
vaccinated some people have had to work
through this too so
that i but i was just immediately fine
and i i recognized that
i think there was a study that came out
uh i believe it was from the uk
that was linked to like anyone with any
kind of um
anxiety disorder like any kind is going
to have a really really tough time
um with you know just trying to accept
going back out into the world like
things are normal again and you know
going to see an orchestra or something
for them that like you said austin
is probably going to be a lot more
difficult than than it ever was before
and
the potential economic risks of that
were like explicitly mentioned and i
have no idea
you know what is going to happen or how
quickly people are going to feel
comfortable if ever
but yeah for me i was amazed that i was
just like
i feel completely normal and i went from
a very
extreme like of especially like
walking outside and being if i ever
needed to go outside being
furious if someone wasn't wearing a mask
so i was like you could murder me
i know that you could and i hate you for
it but then again yeah being vaccinated
was just like
fine i'm fine mentally completely okay
we're all collectively brilliant that's
good
yeah i certainly agree i we're all
basically
tom hanks at the end of castaway uh
we have ice on our glass coming coming
we have ice in our glass uh i wish i'd
lost that much weight
did you know that when they were making
that movie they shot the first half and
then they took
yeah it took like a year off right so he
could lose the weight and grow his beard
and stuff wow so
zemeckis made the harrison ford
michelle pfeiffer movie what lies
beneath during the hiatus in the middle
of the castaway shoot they went and
made an entire other movie wow while
waiting for tom hanks to like safely
come down
this super low scoring matt damon that
[ __ ] right
that's so annoying that from that point
on he just did mocap films
i mean there's the last time he filmed
like live action no he did
he did that movie flight with denzel
washington um
that's true he did but there was a big
period there where it was oh yeah no of
course yeah yeah and it's weird
yeah yeah yeah yeah polar bears polar
and then what else
did the christmas carol movie with um
jim carrey
beowulf did um angelina yeah wolf of
course yeah beowulf
wait wait who was he in beowulf
what we're talking about zemeckis
samantha he was the director i thought
you were talking about tom hanks
this is the future like this is the way
but it did coincide with having to just
do a really awkward film and you do
wonder like how much that was
you know he's like did you guys see his
uh welcome to marwan
uh movie the the like action figures
about it
it's corel right yeah i haven't seen it
either and i consider myself a huge fan
of his but somehow i hadn't i still
haven't seen him didn't it seemed like
it came and went
um but um i i he's made so many
of the best films of all time that uh oh
for sure
he created tech for for mocap like
like the camera system that is still
used was was
was because of bob's mecca he's a
[ __ ] technical visionary yeah i mean
like up there with like lucas
yeah so i i feel like his his whole
foray into
what what can i bring this this uh
medium forward i think he was trying to
build on the shoulder of the giants of
special effects and everything that she
had done with like back to the future it
was like i made a car
fly i made a i made a skateboard hover
can i do this not just that one that
always gets forgotten i remember
watching a behind the scene with bob
hoskins
where he goes oh my god yeah right put
him
back i mean that is a technical feat
that and that film is mind-blowing when
you actually stop and think about what's
going on in who frame roger rabbit which
is what we're talking about i'm just
saying that for the audience there's a
scene of it
yeah the behind the scenes where you've
never seen who framed roger rabbit
oh man oh you showed it's lovely you
showed up
in the call right now this is reaction
who framed roger rabbit i don't know
come back in a year i'll have lost two
stone we'll carry on the podcast from
there
and i know that bob host is by the way
looked at it as like i'm gonna be known
for the [ __ ] movie with the rabbit
jesus christ
because he was such an accomplished
music musician accomplished actor
but if that's the only thing you know
him for it's still
oh yeah that's well defending shot the
story that they tell
me with no dialogue you know exactly who
eddie is
oh my god the thing that that licensing
deals behind
the legalities of like pretty it was the
fortnight of its day
it was um it's fascinating i've
forgotten about the uh
the one that i've seen pointed out that
everyone always forgets is how many
awesome special effects are in um uh
oh god um blubber shrimp um
forrest gump like there's so much
pioneer adding him to all the stock
stuff yeah that was that was massive
back then that was
the um the specific groundbreaking i
wanted to say i was looking at pictures
of who frame rich rabbit
and i don't know how else to phrase this
other than this looks really cool
which feels like the most millennial
thing to say about oh the middle live
action film did it doesn't do it justice
doesn't do it
so this is the book by the guy who did
the animation for that film
which everyone should own yeah it's it's
basically like a cheat sheet for all
animations if every guy
in the theater was like i will have sex
with that with jessica rabbit
that's the part of it that i'm the most
aware of like i've definitely seen that
a lot
if you want to double down iconic cool
world
push that notion was like do you really
because if you haven't seen cool world
with brad pitt and gabriel byrne oh my
kim basinger the uh
wow
there was a behind the scenes with bob
hoskins in that movie where he was
talking about how he did a take where
he goes and he's strangling roger rabbit
and they yell cut and they say bob we're
going to need you to take
we're going to need you to do that again
and when you strangle the rabbit please
do this with your fingers and not don't
strangle him like this strangle him like
this
because if you do this it costs the
production an extra 100 grand
because we got to paint the rabbit in
between your fingers on every frame
wow and so please please strangle the
rabbit like this
seriously we've strangled our rabbits
like this we don't do it like this you
can't you can't you can't strangle a
rabbit trust me i know
you have to do it like this this really
gets them
the thing that people don't realize
puppeteering is in it
because you've got like whenever they're
whenever the characters are holding
physical objects
they don't have cg they have to
puppeteer the objects so they would
build these sets on like
like two feet high sorry two meters high
so
puppeteers underneath are like moving a
mug puppeteering a mug
that they can then animate an animated
character walking around holding
themselves
you got to watch the same frame how much
time
it's amazing dude it had to be it was
ridiculous it won oscars didn't it
yeah but it was like it was one of it
was also pioneering in terms of like its
business model like it was produced in
different countries so
i believe i'm ryan saying but yeah
because richard so richard williams who
wrote this book who everyone should read
is um he was he was kind of the i think
he's credited as like the animation
director so he was the guy who basically
took the shots
did all the animation on top with the
team but he was doing that in the uk so
it was one of those
very early films which had like a
transatlantic production process
nowadays we think nothing of like eight
studios around the world working on the
same movie
i mean god knows how many people like
avengers end game or ubisoft or whatever
but back then like outsourcing literally
they were there was no internet so they
were literally like
having to transport materials back and
forth over the ocean like it's crazy
it won three oscars yeah best visual
effects
best sound design best sound editing
best film editing
also nominated for best sound best art
direction best cinematography and
mike richard williams won a special
achievement oscar
that was a one-off for that year wow for
animation direction and creation of
cartoon characters a special
a special achievement oscar to richard
williams it is a genius and like so much
of his stuff as well has informed
like modern animation like is built on
the shoulders of this guy
like it's crazy how much stuff
yeah squash and stretch and all that
like the like these things existed
obviously like you know disney animators
have been doing them for years but this
was the guy who literally wrote the
textbook that is now used by every
animator in the world
to kind of codify a lot of these systems
and yes the technical wizardry of like
doing that in three-dimensional space
again
perspective just a character like
turning around and moving through a
three-dimensional space done literally
as 2d cell animations
so richard williams would he have also
been on set as the animation director
while i assume he'd have to be just to
make sure that like the mug was being
held in the right place
they could use the shot i assume i
assume it would have to be phenomenal
the um the best one when you watch your
llama because you you should i will
exactly the best moment there is a
moment
um where a character i'm gonna i'm i'm
not gonna spoil it there's a moment
where
bob's washing some dishes oh my god troy
know the scene right
incredibly technically like you're
you're going to be trying to figure out
how it works
one of the best moments in that is
there's a character
threatens him with a gun and if you look
to the side of the shot you can see the
shadow of the gun on a stick
where it's being puppeteered because of
course they didn't have they couldn't
roto out the
the shadow on the wall or paint in the
involved paint in the shadow
so you have this character walking in
with a gun the gun is a practical
three-dimensional object in the space
being puppeted on a stick
and then obviously they've animated a
character holding it you've got this
film's exception
it's so complicated it's ridiculous and
you have to just keep
in your brain around yourself computers
don't exist just repeat that to yourself
as you're watching it like oh sorry
apologies computers existed but computer
animations didn't do that
all of this is being done by painters an
incredible team of artists
by the way 150 million no 50. 50 million
yeah but for that time that was a huge
budget film imdb says 70 million for the
record wikipedia disagreement
thomas was alone cost two million
dollars so we're not going to trust
either the guys
he says i'm a millionaire imdb always
it's weird how high budget movies
always are underestimated so they look
maximally profitable and low budget
indies trying to look like trying to
flex always have high
estimated budget so yes you're right
basically don't trust any numbers on
imdb
i um the thing that that i remember
from when that movie came out is 89 is
that right is that when that movie came
out
88 88. um not bad guys
um the whole yeah the marketing pick it
up
it's unacceptable just a lot of the
marketing
look at this technical feat look what
they're doing and it wasn't even about
here's the story it wasn't about
anything other than it's like
you're not going to believe you're going
to and like entertainment
was i feel sold similarly right like
avatar was all about i think he was born
more about the secrecy of what you know
james cameron's been where james cameron
what he's been working on for the last
10 years
but this was you're gonna go back to the
theater
for a cartoon even if you're an adult
and people are like what and they're
like we're just going to show you a
little bit
and one of it was you know in the taxi
when they're like this is a cartoon but
they're
it it's the practical world and the
conceit of the movie
is people in the real world reacting or
or enacting uh uh interacting with
this cartoon world and it was just the
conceit of it was brilliant everything
about them
well that's also all that went when you
watch as an adult and realize that it's
actually like a
like a metaphor for like america and
race essentially like you watch that
movie again you're like
oh there were layers to this that i
missed as a kid
we're also only talking about the
technical side of it is it also a good
movie is it a good story
yeah fantastic it's a classic film noir
detective story like but just where half
the cast are cartoon characters wow
you're gonna love it i'm genuinely
excited a lot of them for you to watch
this
i didn't know about it
it's like on the back of the back to the
future success it was like
now let's do this was that his that was
his his inception his do whatever the
hell you want movie was it was that
back to the future was was yeah the
first one i think the first because i'm
saying
what was this was this his point cashing
in his check basically was his project
right
i don't think he i got because i think
three came out in 91
back to the future three came out i
think 91 but back to the future one and
two
would probably come out at this point
because because back to the future one
was 85
and i think part two was either 87
right that would track i think two and
three were that was the first time where
a sequel and a third movie were filmed i
think simultaneously simultaneously and
it said to be
to be continued and he was like i gotta
do another one
and so they said yes and then it said to
be concluded at the end and they they
it was the first time i remember they
showed what happens
mean james bond movies do this all the
time is like james bond will return in
and they knew they were gonna do
something else but they actually showed
parts of
three at the end of part two and
because they filmed them so that would
have been so he would have finished
those we're working out like the
scheduling of a movie
in the late 80s so he would have then
been able to move on to who frame raja
rabbit and he would have had a couple of
years
according to this it was it was
production back to future 85
and then who framed roger rabbit 88 and
then 89 90 of the two
subsequent backs 89.90 oh okay so this
was sandwiched in between
in the middle of the trilogy but you're
right this is this is the caching of the
check this is you made all the money
with back to the future
what's your dream project and he because
you only get to cash that check a couple
of times in your career this is
jaws okay do you do your alien movie now
yeah now do close encounters
yeah yeah yeah i love the story you were
telling about seeing the
shadow of the of the puppeteering rig i
love
those little trivia i remember when um
they were remastering in 97 the star
wars films and they were like
obviously changing and updating and
doing a lot of controversial tweaks to
the special effects
one of the things they were doing was
going back and fixing things like that
that were in there and there was one
that i that i i always thought was funny
that i'd never spotted as a kid
but i've got my you know my vhs of the
original trilogy and it's absolutely
there and that was one of those things
they got rid of was
during the battle of hoth and empire
strikes back there's that iconic shot of
the pov
of the snow speeder where it goes in
between the legs of one of the at-80s
and then takes a few shots at the other
one flies over top the second one so it
does this kind of
you know arcing maneuver and it was one
of those where they basically just
rigged the camera to to to fly through
the thing and then they superimposed the
image of a cockpit
because what you realize when you look
at it is that the
shadow of the atat is in front of the
cockpit
uh image in the in the shot in the
original film
no one clocked it because it's sort of
like dark on a slightly different shade
of dark
but it was one of those where they were
going through and they were painting in
the cockpit to like actually make it
believable that was one of the like i
was watching a documentary back then of
things that they were changing and it
was because it wasn't all just
you know adding monsters and stuff some
of it was things like this you know you
can see the shadow of the puppet rig
because we had no way to get rid of it
well now
you know we want to get rid of it and i
don't begrudge that but it's but it's
still cool i like the little
typical i like the little uh telltale
signs of the techniques you know
then does that translate to doing the
viability
and validity of doing a remake like we
talked about last week
boom ongoing narrative we've serialized
the show yes
yes what do you mean i was gonna say
that's i think that's what
you mean does that like does that does
that mean
and the preservation of look what they
couldn't do which makes something like
who framed roger rabbit i
was like look what they did do i think
you're what's the greatest magic trick
you ever saw
yeah but this is talking about the
original thing was
erased it was like we can get this we
now star wars is a very atypical example
i always thought it was very strange
that they made such a concerted effort
to bury pre-existing
versions because it's also very everyone
would always accuse them of doing
everything as a cash grab but i'm like
the ultimate cash grab would be to offer
all the versions yeah like it's clearly
done out of a kind of neurotic
auteur sensibility of i need my work to
be perfect and i don't want anybody to
touch the imperfect predecessor versions
which you can always still get
it's just hard yeah but it's like
all but like you got to meet a guy out
of a van pretty much yeah
they've gone well the great thing there
is where people have done the
de-specialized editions right which
obviously i've never seen because that
would be piracy
um but i've heard um
amazing visual effects people have gone
back and basically added all the flaws
back
in and it's incredible i would assume
um because it it's the closest you get
to what that film was back in the day
and that's that's incredibly interesting
to me the amount of work someone will
now do to add back in those little
errors and glitches and and get it get
it right
and and what that does to the movie i
also feel like this is a little bit less
of a remake
troy and a bit more of a patch
right that's true it's just films being
patched they're broken on launch you
could see the
the shadow of the puppet deal with the
gun i can't believe it
released this way and then 20 years
later they fix it
okay so whatever that's the exciting
thing about creatively like
creative but technical uh mediums
is is everything's broken what about
every game you've ever played is broken
every movie
there's bits in avengers where like
armor is clipping on thanos's chest
and one day someone might want to fix
that but like it doesn't matter
if you push against that wall you're
gonna create errors
and that's exciting to me like that's
the stuff that fascinates me in game
development is like
faking stuff and like breaking things in
a way that's in that just about works is
is
the joy of the of the work so what about
like 4k blu-ray and
now restored to it's you know
you're able to watch it in um a higher
resolution than you've ever been able to
to see is is that for a film is that
it's an update that's your ps5 update
well it depends if it's a transfer
because what people always forget is
that
film is 4k it's actually higher than
that it's weird yeah there's
it's an analog so there's no 4k is a
digital translation exactly yeah so
you're not like
so a lot of like film transfers like you
know
seeing a 4k is actually technically more
accurate to the filmmaker's original
intent because they would have edited on
film and blah blah
but the um the stuff that's fascinating
to me is color grading like have you
seen all the controversy around the
matrix recently
um because the me so the matrix was
like basically uh color corrected wrong
for the dvd and vhs and blu-ray version
that we've all seen so that green that
heavy green tint yeah
wasn't in the movie in the cinema
version no way it's wait wait
wait hold on a second because i remember
not to the exam the wachowskis were
talking specifically that they
wanted the especially the real world to
have that
uh another real world but the the matrix
world to have a green
tint to it it and it does so the art
direction of the
environment so there's like green on the
walls there's green in the costumes
there's green
but what they did in the sequels was
they really like
because it was that time after um oh
brother art thou where everyone was
really going all in on the color
correction
with the sequels to the matrix
everything is cranked up to 11 like
they're very vividly green
but when you look at the dvd transfer
and and
later the blu-ray transfer they
basically went back and color corrected
the first movie to kind of
mirror the aesthetics of the sequels the
very ramped up color correction and
apparently now the the version that's
just coming out now in 4k which looks
so much better because it's not been
like post-processed
and you don't go all the kind of
glitches that have come with that um
is much more kind of quote-unquote
naturalistic in terms of like skin tones
and stuff
so that's a completely different take so
that's an interesting one where
the image in our head of how the matrix
looks because we've all seen the dvd and
the blu-ray and all that stuff
is wrong to what the original cinema
release of that film was
i'm sure the wachowskis were happy with
the dvd i'm sure they oversaw it but
like it isn't accurate to what the
original release was
so now now the version that's the update
the remaster the remake whatever
is actually more correct than what we've
seen as the intermediary stage
can't think of an example of that
happening in games where like a port has
become like the de facto version and got
something i feel like
it's interesting the this isn't the
parallel but the closest i can think of
is like a lot of switch ports end up
having
more content that's not
super uncommon um and that's the thing
that becomes a definitive version of the
game
like you've got to play it on the switch
which um i think it's the
overlap between industries where this
stuff is concerned
is really interesting and that i wonder
if
you know people in in the video game
community can be very critical of any of
this kind of stuff i wonder if that
exists for people who are
making podcasts just about film where
they're like well you updated it or like
the dvd is
is incorrect like oh i guarantee you the
mate the only reason i know about the
matrix thing is like 50 youtube videos
happened about it
there were people that wanted to be a
massive i'll share with you
people were super interesting wanted to
make ted turner a pariah for
for you know colorizing it's a wonderful
life and how dare you you're destroying
the
authenticity and the integrity of the
original it's supposed to be black and
white he's like but i want to show you
what it would look like today
i was thinking about peter jackson did
the world war one documentary they shall
not grow old
if you haven't seen it it's it's it's
truly fascinating and
i feel it's a little it's a little long
because once you get it but what he did
was
he um sped up he got the film
and of course they ran like 15 you know
uh frames typically or somewhere around
there
was it even well it's it's erratic like
right silence it was hand cranked it's
not like a consistent
yeah so that's why everything looks
always very stop starty in in old school
and so he brought it to 60 frames
enhanced it
colorized it added vo and effects
and was able to actually go and go what
are they saying and they were able to
transcribe and then record
and so they hired lip readers to do it
right inside lip readers to like go
through the footage and work out what
was being said
have voice actors do it it's weird to
watch because it looks like it was
filmed yesterday on your iphone
and you're like that's the weird one for
me is how awful everyone's teeth are
that's the one that really jumps out you
right like you're like because it you
don't notice it like but when when it's
like all super sharp you're like wow
dentist
dentistry's come along as a british
person that's saying something i was
gonna make that i know right like
for you it would be a step beyond
i had that line in the chamber and then
i was like
nah that's a little bit uh i did that
too i didn't think about it
she was like she was like she came up to
him prison style in the shower and just
wait okay
okay not that i hesitated i was like
maybe i shouldn't
at least in the uk everyone can go to
the dentist but you know
that's fair i don't want to talk about
it those were his dying words
not to get political
[Music]
um i to me is that a
uh um an example of
now you're able to see the way that it
was it could have been and and you now
have a new appreciation for it
um or is it no we want we want that to
be erratic hand cranked we want to see
what it looked like then
to me this mentality is is transcendent
it is unilateral
it speaks so much about us
sociologically
do we want this is the preserve our
culture or do we
change our past do we realize that these
were the mistakes that we made
and we realize that they are a part of
our history
so that we can understand it and move
forward or do we go
we need to tear down statues to me
they're they're part of the same
conversation
i think foundation is a really
interesting one is do we let this decay
and fall apart or do we fix it now
and change it i have no idea last time
yeah but the last time we did this we
were chopping off penises and covered up
boobies
you know what i mean like we the the
catholic church went through and did the
great emasculation
that's where the fig leaves came from
artists weren't going you know we should
do it put fig leaves
they went through and after the paint
was done
they put them on or they chopped off
they lopped off body parts
because they all just randomly decided
that was blasphemous
even though clearly the bible never
teaches that yeah so i don't want to get
into that thing where we need to be able
to say
maybe this is obscene and maybe this was
considered profane
we no longer do it but we need to
recognize that this was
what it was i don't think we should go
destroying [ __ ] there were episodes of a
show recently that were
something tina fey was involved in but i
don't i don't know which
show um where there were 30 rock you're
thinking where they removed some
episodes
yeah they they chose to remove some
episodes and i guess like
my thought process on that i mean
there's also been the dr seuss stuff
is generally if that's what the creator
of that thing wants to do
that's that's that's up to them i think
disney plus right now
try to go through and find an original
disney classic it they
bury them like dumbo buried
that you can get them but you gotta look
and then there will be some stuff that
has a
um a preamble a prologue to it going
this is we're preserving it but we're
letting you know that this has some
stuff that is culturally insensitive
providing that context is really useful
i think context is fine but don't go
changing
and like let's re-dub the crows and
change their dialogue
it's the same you have to do a lot to
make dumbo okay by modern stuff do you
really
i've not seen it since i was a kid they
did this just literally
they did this one of the birds is
literally called jim crow yeah that's
not great
and i'm the vocal performance is exactly
what you were about yeah that's where
you
it because it is a relic of its era i
find it all the more
informative important to preserve as a
re as a
as an it teaches you about like look
what was acceptable
then like yeah we've we've come a long
way and i think that
you know it it's we don't i don't see
what's gained especially if you
if you put that that sort of warning up
front that says just so you know
you know this hasn't aged particularly
well but i i find it i
mean that's a good but that's i think
that makes sense i think that's a good
way of handling it i really do
i think i agree and i think also the
statue thing you know
i know statues it's a more heightened
deal but like i think a lot of those
statues belong
in history in museums as well i'm
talking about
i agree with that i i say get rid of
this but somewhere else
crucial thing with a lot of the statute
the kinds of statues that you're taught
that sorry that that are
being discussed in this way were not
contemporarily
built they weren't they weren't put up
in the time of the event they were put
up with a very specific purpose
by 800 years later in a lot of cases
right like they were they were
they weren't they were symbolic of the
time they were put up
more so arguably than the people that
they were commemorating it was the
context there
so that's really interesting to have
that conversation and and i think
it does but it doesn't belong in a park
i don't want to walk past that every day
you know
and generated museums are a great place
of kind of talking about those
museums demolition the hall what was it
called the hall of violence or whatever
you could go in there yeah can i get a
gun um
i love how in that museum all the guns
are like loaded and working
that was that was my favorite detail of
that scene it's a very silly movie
simon freeze simon uh i just watched it
too and i'm blanking
simon says that what that what i love
about that movie is it it's of the same
talk about this recently in an episode
because i also said yeah i also
described
phoenix simon phoenix i've watched i've
watched it for the first time
and john spartan demolition man john
spartan you are fine
one credit for violation it's just
happened we have to go with that it's
fine i think uh
art changes over time contexts you know
re-evaluate
and then we just talk about demolition
man over and over and over
taco bell thing see that's that ties
into exactly what we're talking about
i can always funnel it into either
demolition man or time cop
guarantee um ron silver just showed up
in west wing and i'm like
no no no you're senator or president
macomb depending upon the timeline
and it's just freaking me out for anyone
who doesn't know with demolition man
i feel like this is pretty well known
in the us version the only restaurant to
survive
the franchise wars is taco bell in
australia and
i think most of europe it's pizza hotel
in the uk yeah um because we don't have
taco bell
so i think he's on camera though when he
says that i'd like to take you to
taco bell yeah it's all edited around
and dubbed
the only the only thing that they didn't
manage to do was when
they actually walk into the restaurant
there's a taco bell sign that's like on
the glass
that stage and the food of course is not
pizza right
yeah uh same's true what they they
actually then like
because i think i think that demolition
man was one of the first case of that
being done
and then it was scooby where scooby-doo
i think one taco bell just opened in
london
subsequently there was a dysentery
what are we going to say about
scooby-doo so scooby-doo has
separately recorded scenes for different
regions
which promote foods like basically
different sponsors
so there's actually like different it's
the stuff troy says like the on-camera
speech or the sign in the background
they literally like
shot alts of certain scenes for that
movie um
for different because i think they had
like a different i i can't remember
i feel like they had like a mcdonald's
deal in the us and a burger king deal in
the uk or something like that
so they had like full-on different
scenes i mean the uh australian version
weird moment in yeah the australian
version of the the original
south park game is different
um sorry i shouldn't have said the
original uh the stick of truth
is different in australia because any
kind of um
that makes me feel very old that that's
the original yeah sorry
the original of the new ones it would be
like saying the original doom when i
mean doom 93 that's
my fault but uh the the stick of truth
the original playstation you know the
ps4
the ps4 um because
any kind of interactive sexual violence
is not allowed in video games in
australia there's
the ideas of censorship and video games
in australia i think is generally
over-inflated like people ask me about
it so much that i'm like
this is not the australian version's
always watered down super common well
it's not not all the time so you're not
allowed to have incentivized drug use
for drugs that have
real world names um you can't hurt
children i think that that's the case
pretty much everywhere though and you
can't have
any like i said interactive sexual
violence
uh which i feel like i'm all right with
um so this is
great things i think that's a good way
to look at a dev and go hey listen great
things remove troy who you mean there
right just to just to confirm
those things just just just just do you
a favor
on the podcast yeah i
i think um you know where it was and
here comes greg miller
god damn it i think the sexual violence
one i i
uh people disagree with especially in
that case because
it was controversial to take something
out of his southpaw game but
my stance is i'm like i'm okay with not
having
sex what was the sexual violence that
there were you have to press a button
to you know unconsensually anal probe
a randy um then that's a whole bit is
that you are the one who is
interactively
effectively sexually assaulting randy
yeah yes yeah if i go to the doctor
i i'm trying to picture i play well
you're consenting to the doctor
it's on the spaceship you're a
consenting partner um in the australian
version
right the thing worth noting is that i
think what they did is funniest
the australian version gives you um
this picture of a koala crying with like
a didgeridoo playing
in the background and some people like
this and it's this really condescending
text that's like oh australia
we have to censor this because whatever
whatever um so every time that you would
press that button to do that it just
gives you this crying koala and i was
like i think this is infinitely funnier
than what is actually happening this is
by the way this is a family
100 but this is this is literally a
family guy episode where they talk about
you know he has to go get a prostate
exam
and the recontextualization of it we had
to completely change
in shadow of war or shadow mortar
actually for uh for
the japanese version there's no
beheading allowed
so that's like well that's kind of what
you do you chop off the heads of works
they're like
nope not here wow in germany they
changed the poster for uncharted because
the gun was there
you're not allowed to point the gun at
the audience at the camera at the camera
so they had to move the gun off to the
side any kind of nazi imagery and
there was yeah i was going to say i just
was i was having a conversation just the
other day about how the original
bioshock
um in the audio logs there's reference
to
i think tenenbaum uh learning science on
in auschwitz uh and the german sensors
uh made the line get changed to like a
prison camp or something generic maybe
even though she's like clearly like a
jewish
you know victim of the holocaust and
it's extremely contextually specific
that like rapture is born out of this
out of the you know the after effects of
that scientifically
um they were like nope uh
it's probably that the laws are so
specific in terms of
needing to emit that kind of thing that
context can't have a silly one
here we have silly one here where
there's certain
elements of government that can't but
you can't show
i'm going to get this wrong you can't
show why is mike not a
podcast anymore whisked away
you can't you can't show what basically
you can't show footage of mps in
westminster
in the context of a comedy program wow
so
so whenever we have so whenever like um
like last week tonight
john oliver always has to do this yes
whenever there's footage
in an american like satirical comedy
show
about uh about about this happening
and they uh and they rebroadcast it here
they always have like a bit
of like to camera and yeah john oliver
will often like sing a song or something
like to fill the fill the space
basically where he's like you know the
americans i think one time they just
played fart sounds
on john oliver for like three it's a
ridiculous show because like
yeah it's there's stuff like that in the
uk has some weird laws
that is a very odd one though i mean
that's a weirdly
defensive posture um yeah well
well we have some strange governmental
set up in this country okay
so yeah i have to go me too immediately
i was like yeah
game director and that's also when
you're using video and proposal we'll
see you all next week bye